[Music]
imagine being so strong and so powerful
that you could physically melt metal
with your hands gold iron and even
titanium what would you melt are there
ways we can do this today and what
temperature would your hands need to be
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you could melt metal with your
hands technically yes you can melt metal
with your hands but not every type of
metal there is a metal that is so soft
it can melt at just under 30 degrees
this metal is called gallium and after
playing around with it in your hands for
just a couple of seconds it quickly
liquefies there are other metals as well
that have the same melting temperature
such as francium cesium but you're going
to want to stay away from them as
they're radioactive can catch on fire if
they're not handled properly the great
thing about gallium is it's entirely
safe for you to use it's essentially
just extremely expensive playdough
but we can already melt these metals
what would it be like if you could melt
every type of metal melting metal is
pretty difficult a regular campfire
flame won't be able to do the trick
it takes an incredibly high temperature
to melt metal and to do this we need
foundries boundaries are used to reach
extremely high temperatures and maintain
them depending on what you want to melt
like gold for example the temperature
needs to be nearly 1,000 degrees this
means that in order for you to melt
metal your hands would need to be at
least this hot
and since the max temperature your body
can get to before dying is a measly 44
degrees you'd end up melting yourself if
your body went up to this temperature
but let's assume you'd survive if you
want it to melt metal you'd have to be a
walking furnace not only would you be
able to melt aluminum iron and steel
you'd also be melting just about
everything else you touched that's
because you'd be as hot as molten lava
you'd be a giant fireball of destruction
but as quickly as you destroy everything
around you you'd be just as easily
destroyed but how let's assume you're
doing your thing and burning up some
metal all of a sudden it starts raining
suddenly a massive explosion would occur
that's due to the water reacting with
the hot molten metal if water or any
sort of moisture touches the melting
metal it will expand to 1,600 times
larger than its original volume this
creates a massive steam explosion that
spreads the hot liquid metal if you're
not extremely careful you're bound to
cause some severe damage to things and
people you won't want to hurt melting
metal with our bare hands might sound
like it could be fun
but there's no reason you'd ever want to
do it apart from looking pretty metal is
used in all kinds of electronics cars
and even in some prescription drugs
metals are an essential part of the
world we live in and we definitely
wouldn't want to go around destroying
and melting all of them but what would
the world be like if metal never existed
well that sounds like a story for
another what if
you